[Music]
well good afternoon just everybody uh
this um
was going to be a lecture but i decided
it would be better to do a sort of far
side chat
so this is the session
which all those questions you've
wondered about in cosmology but have
been afraid to ask will be answered and
so i would like you to feel free to
interrupt but i'd like to say first of
all what a pleasure it is to be back
here in hampstead so i grew up within
walking distance of where we are now
somewhere over there and
as a teenager i'd love to walk over
hampstead heath and look up at the sky
you could still see it in those days and
wonder about how the universe came to be
put together and i was determined to
make a career
in cosmology theoretical physics with
special applications of astrophysics and
cosmology and i did i've lived through
the golden age of cosmology where it's
gone from a speculative backwater
such a long time ago i didn't tell you
speculative backwater when i was a
student to a precision science today and
like all golden ages in science a lot of
questions get answered but then a lot of
new questions appear and we're very far
from understanding the universe in its
entirety and so i'm pleased there's some
young people here and maybe people who
are even
working in science or thinking about
science there's still a lot left to do
and so now i work in arizona at arizona
state university and again it's a
pleasure to be back in cloudy london
after the unrelenting blue skies and
warm sunshine
of arizona but they the great advantage
of having blue sky is that it's good for
astronomy and so arizona's like a world
center for astronomy now it's been many
decades since i've actually looked
through a telescope it's all done up
here
it's theoretical physics for me so it's
equations and concepts
but a lot of people do practical
astronomy and in a sense cosmology began
in arizona i think it's not well known
uh to the north of phoenix where i live
is the town called flagstaff and there
in the 1890s a rich businessman percival
lowell built an observatory to look for
martians he believed that mars was
inhabited and the martians had built
canals and he built this observatory to
make maps of the canals of miles you can
still see them he published a book these
maps entirely figment of his imagination
but meanwhile a secondary project was
taking place a little known astronomer
called vesto slifer and he was
interested in the fuzzy patches that you
see in the sky
you can even see some with the naked eye
these are called nebulae and there was a
big debate around about 1900 where the
nebulae like other milky way is way way
out
full of stars or were they just patches
of gas within our own milky way and he
studied those and he found a very
curious thing that the fainter ones the
color was redder
than the brighter ones
and he had a ready explanation for that
because if something's rushing away from
us the light is shifted towards the red
it's called the red shift it's well
understood it was understood at the time
so he deduced that um the ones that are
farther away were receding faster and
this came to the attention of a pipe
smoking astronomer called
edwin hubble
uh and you probably heard of hubble and
so hubble took slifer's results and
confirmed that these with a bigger
telescope and mel wilson confirmed that
these
fainter fuzzy patches were in fact
galaxies in their own right like the
milky way and then he published it in
all places the new york times in 1924
the declaration that the universe is
expanding that these other galaxies were
rushing away from us and that
immediately raised the question uh well
if the universe is getting bigger must
have been smaller in the past
and so if you go back billions of years
everything was squashed together in one
place what did that mean where did it
come from and nobody was really uh
prepared to grasp the nettle at that
stage it fell to
a belgian priest
in the late 1920s uh called the abe
lemaitre george lemaitre
and
he said well what this means is that the
universe burst into existence in what
later became called the big bang and so
the genesis of that was back in the
1920s but it fell on deaf ears einstein
wrote to lemaitre and said
that
your equations are good but your physics
is atrocious so nobody really wanted to
believe it and fast forward some decades
so when i was a student i keep alluding
to this and stop me if it's too boring
it's what happens when you get old you
think a lot about your youth
but in the in the 50s and 60s there was
an alternative theory of the universe
called the steady state theory
and that said that as the universe
expands new matter
is trickles in continuously so there
wasn't a big bang in fact the person who
the architect of the steady state theory
fred hoyle at cambridge university he
coined the term big bang as a term of
division he was on some radio
program and he said and some people
think that the universe began you know
with just a big bang
and so he didn't like that idea at all
but in
1964 two radio engineers at the bell
labs in new jersey accidentally
discovered an annoying hiss coming from
space
and
what they deduced after a lot of tests
was that this hiss was in fact
microwaves from the big bang it's like
the fading afterglow if the universe
began with this
very dense state it would have been very
hot and that heat hasn't got anywhere to
go it's still in the universe today it
bathes the whole universe at about three
degrees above absolute zero
they detected it and it was immediately
apparent that there must have been a big
bang but also
that buried
in that background heat radiation would
be really important information about
the first split second of the universe
and so over the decades a number of
satellites have been launched there's
one up there at the moment called planck
european space agency to map that heat
radiation
with extraordinary precision
and some of you may know what i'm
talking about a sort of color-coded heat
map of the sky um usually that shape uh
with
blue and red blotches uh slightly
hotter and slightly cooler parts the the
overwhelming result that you get from
mapping this radiation is that it's
extraordinarily smooth across the sky
the radiation over there and the
radiation over there the temperatures
match uh to within a few parts
per million but on smaller scales there
are slight variations and there have
better be because those variations
represent
back in the early universe slight
increase or decrease of density of
material and when you had denser
material
the gravitational pull was greater
and so they what those
cooler bits represent is
denser patches they like the seeds of
the clusters of galaxies so without that
there would be no galaxies
no stars and no people to celebrate what
a wonderful universe were in so it began
in a state of perfect but not totally of
almost perfect but not totally perfect
uniformity
and i myself worked i i should just
throw this in
self-commercial in the 1970s
and this is how science gets done in the
1970s i had a student by the name of tim
bunch i was at king's college in london
in those days and
we were trying to solve the equations of
quantum physics in an expanding universe
and we've done sort of one or two
examples there's a particular example
that where the equations are easy and
it's a universe that doubles in size in
a fixed time some people know that's
called exponential growth
uh and uh so i got tim to work on that
and he solved everything wonderfully and
we published all that and we thought
well nobody's ever going to be
interested in quantum effects in this uh
it's called the situ space expanding
space and it was only about three years
later that suddenly uh the favored
theory of the big bang
uh burst on the scene it's called the
inflationary universe scenario and it
says that in the first split second of
the universe
it leapt in size by an enormous factor
as if like the universe had taken a
sudden deep breath and it just ballooned
up and then that it slowed down to a
more sedate expansion and that
ballooning phase was precisely what tim
and i had had worked on
and so if you
if you take those equations and apply
them uh to the early universe you get
that pattern of ripples
we wouldn't be here without that
particular
quantum effect so it's really like
quantum fluctuations writ large and
frozen in the sky
yet yes because this this is a long
story yes yes a lady here we have a big
bang and you said and it expanded
exponentially and then slowed down yes
yes you're absolutely right why is
a switch the question is uh i've said
you know gambling through this that in
the first split second the universe
ballooned inside it expanded
exponentially then it uh
that stopped and it's now then after
that it was expanding at a decelerating
rate
very briefly why is that gravity
is the dominating force in cosmology
gravity as you know is a pulling force
it keeps our feet on the ground it pulls
on the galaxies so as the universe was
expanding
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you